In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, per June 4th, on which we commemorate our Holy Father,
Metrophonies, Archbishop of Constantinople.
On the 4th of the month we celebrate the memory of our Holy Father, Metrophonies, Archbishop
of Constantinople.
The great Metrophonies was the Son of Demetias, brother of the Roman Emperor, Probus.
The grace of God allowed Demetias to realize the useless deception of idolatrous cults,
and he was converted to Christ and baptized.
He then went to Byzantium at that time, a town of little renown, where he settled with
his two sons, Probus and Metrophonies.
He attached himself to Titus, the Bishop of the town, a holy man inspired by God, who
accepted him among the clergy and made him his successor.
After having governed the local church for 24 years through various persecutions, he fell
asleep in peace, and his son, Probus, assumed charge of the church for some 12 years, after
which Metrophonies, whom all admired for his virtue and his wise balance, was elected
to succeed him.
It was he whom Constantine the Great found on the Episcopal throne when he decided to make
Byzantium his new capital, and it is said that he chose the city not only because of its
privileged position at the crossroads of East and West, and its climate, but also because
of the holiness of its Bishop.
It was necessary only to see him to respect him, even on the part of the most arrogant.
Saint Metrophonies, having become aged and confined to bed by illness, was not able to attend
the First Ecumenical Council in 325, but he sent Alexander, the most senior of his priests,
in whom he had full confidence to Nysia.
When the Emperor's return to Constantinople after the Council, he went to visit the Holy
Hierarch, who told him that he had received a revelation in which he had learned that Alexander
and Paul would assume the direction of the church after him.
He fell asleep a few days later at the age of 117 after receiving the homage of the Consilier
fathers.
It is said that his funeral service was celebrated by Saint James, Bishop of Nysivis.
His precious relics placed in a church which he had built in the district of Eptuscalon,
were burned during the persecution by Constantin Coprónimos.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.